y otro día nos detenemos a hacer un
repaso sobre los candidatos republicanos
las primarias hoy vamos a hacer lo mismo
con los candidatos demócratas en este
caso el catálogo es bastante más
reducido pero aún así tenemos nuestro
propios personajes nuestro propio
incluso donald trump
así es bernie sanders que a pesar de sus
74 años y de ser muy radical de
izquierdas pero muy radical se ha
convertido contra todo pronóstico en una
auténtica estrella mediática de hecho
estaba viendo muy cara su derrota en el
proceso de primarias del partido
demócrata frente a él
hillary clinton la famosa hillary hoy
vamos a ver en qué se diferencian y qué
similitudes mantienen vamos a ello
en primer lugar tenemos a hillary
clinton
bueno pues alguien vive debajo de una
roca y no sabe quién es gira de clinton
recordamos brevemente que es una abogada
de prestigio tiene 68 años ha sido
activista su etapa más joven luego fue
primera dama junto a su nuevo marido a
bill clinton después secretaria de
estado y senadora y hay que recordar que
ahora mismo le está saliendo un poco de
porquería de su etapa de escritora de
estado porque se le ocurrió utilizar su
correo del técnico personal para tratar
temas secretos en vez de utilizar el
correo cifrado del gobierno de eeuu
bernie sanders tampoco es un neófito la
política norteamericana
alcalde congresista y senador ahora
busca romper todos los moldes
decidiéndose como socialista un término
tabú en los eeuu
además aunque los medios de comunicación
no suelen obviar ver mí es muy
nacionalista
de hecho encarna perfectamente aquel
lema que podríamos denominar como
américa para los americanos y de hecho
su masa de votos es equivalente a la de
donald trump
a ver me le votan sobre todo población
blanca población rural y jóvenes y qué
papel tiene y hillary clinton en tras
primer es bueno puede ser que decir que
hillary clinton es la candidata moderada
dentro del partido demócrata y porque es
la candidata moderada bueno pues porque
tiene un discurso bastante flexible por
no decir que no se suele mojar mucho
nunca e incluso cambia de discurso de
hecho hasta hace poco en su página web
no podíamos encontrar nada acerca de su
programa electoral pero en cambio lo que
sí podíamos encontrar
eran millones de fotos sobre su historia
de amor con su marido
en el caso de hillary sus votantes se
encuentran entre las minorías entre las
mujeres y la población urbana
una masa electoral más amplia que la de
bernie que hace que tenga más
posibilidades para ser finalmente la
nominada por el partido demócrata pero
que tienen en común bernís hilary bueno
pues en ciertas áreas hay que reconocer
que siguen un camino bastante paralelo
aunque sonando esos izquierdas hay que
decir que girar es un poquito menos por
ejemplo en el marco de la sanidad
hillary apuesta por seguir la dirección
de bakker es decir una colaboración
público privada mientras bernie sanders
lo que hace es defender un seguro
público que trate de garantizar la
sanidad para todo el mundo algo parecido
que tenemos en españa
en casi cualquier tipo es de white hart
el tema de la educación pues tres
cuartas partes de lo mismo me traste
girar y defiende que el gobierno federal
dé dinero a los estados para que éstos
reduzcan las tasas universitarias y
además también propone tratar de
los intereses en los préstamos
universitarios revisan desde más allá y
lo que propone directamente es las
universidades públicas sean gratuitas
zúrich en el terreno el salario mínimo y
el dispone que sea de 12 horas la hora y
berni pues un poco más de 15 dólares por
otra parte en el terreno de las
inversiones en infraestructuras hillary
propone una inversión de 250 mil
millones de euros y bernie sanders pues
va mucho más allá propone una inversión
cuatro veces mayor de un billón de euros
en otros campos las políticas de ambos
candidatos siguen caminos contrapuestos
el caso más claro es probablemente su
visión del comercio y la globalización
bernie como decíamos antes encarna el
nacionalismo que tiene como lema américa
para los americanos y por ello se opone
a los tratado de libre comercio los
culpa de hecho de haber destruido
millones de puestos de trabajo y en lo
que persigue es defender la industria
nacional de la competencia exterior
hillary al contrario entiende que el
comercio de los pueblos es bueno para la
actividad económica y para la generación
de nuestro trabajo y a lo largo de su
trayectoria política siempre ha
descendido los acuerdos de libre
comercio se hizo en el caso del nafta y
también lo ha hecho la negociación del
reciente acuerdo de libre comercio del
pacífico' lo que ocurre es que ahora
hillary le interesa decir que ella no
estaba tan de acuerdo con este tipo de
políticas y ha introducido muchos
matices a su declaración del pasado pero
la evidencia empírica es clara ella como
obama siempre han sido defensores del
libre comercio
en política exterior también ambos
caneto son muy diferentes
hillary es todo un halcón cuyos
postulados acercamos a los del partido
republicano
long action en partners arts trading
mientras que bernie sanders es como no
muy heterodoxo la materia de hecho tiene
dos políticas dos propuestas principales
una abandonar afganistán porque dice que
esta emisión sólo le ha costado dolor y
sacrificio al pueblo norteamericano y en
la guerra contra crisis darle liderazgo
a los propios países musulmanes y en
concreto ver me hablaba arabia saudita
algo que es muy controvertido por
ejemplo yo personalmente me cuesta mucho
creer que un país como ahora de saudita
una tecnocracia que viola
sistemáticamente los derechos humanos
pueda ser solucionada pero así es ver
y por último en política económica aquí
hemos cambiado se ha mantenido un tenso
rifirrafe si es que bernie culpa hillary
de ser la candidata de eeuu street y de
estar comprada por el dinero de los
grandes bancos no me ayudes war in the
world is big band que es efectivo neta
donados por speech learning cambio lo
que quiere hacer es romper estos grandes
bancos porque dice que si una entidad
financiera es demasiado grande para caer
simplemente no tiene que existir y que
con bancos pequeñitos el riesgo sería
mucho más controlable y en impuestos
bueno a ver no le gusta gastar y para
gastar tiene que recaudar por eso
propone un plan fiscal que es
auténticamente desmesurado quiere subir
todos los impuestos habidos y por haber
incluso e inventarse en muchos nuevos si
pensamos en españa que conectando en
rojo y motor habíamos conocido la
quintaesencia de la codicia tributaria
bueno lo cierto es que bernie le supera
concreto
no
para hacernos una idea bernie quiere
subir impuestos cada año por el
equivalente a todos los impuestos que se
recaudan en españa nuestra más verdad de
hecho quiere subir impuestos a todo el
mundo a los ricos pero también los que
no son ricos y de hecho el salario medio
en eeuu con bernie pagaría cuatro mil
quinientos dólares más cada año
hillary como no aquí es mucho más
lograda y aunque se habla de subir
impuestos a los ricos en algunas lagunas
tributarias lo cierto es que también
contempla favorecer la reinversión con
alivios fiscales favorecer a las pymes y
darle cierto acomodos tributarios a las
familias que tengan que realizar
nuestros extraordinarios como puede ser
pagar la universidad a sus hijos y con
todo esto que hemos comentado si tuviera
que elegir a un candidato entre bernie y
hillary pues la vas que personalmente me
quedaba con hillary aunque no sea santo
de mi devoción es cierto que darle me da
un poquito de miedo no lo que se llama
el tipo realmente pero éste monismo o
socialista que trata de arreglar todo a
base de decretazos como pues en españa
tenemos a podemos no la verdad que me
dan un poco de miedo y bueno ya los
republicanos en estas primarias están de
vuelta y media es decir no yo cualquier
presidente de eeuu que quede claro que
la inmigración no es un problema y
quieren siempre ha tenido claro girar y
fugarse lo que quieras pero a
reconocidos asumidos como la tierra de
libertad y de los sueños
por eso mismo yo me enojo y voto por
hillary clinton estoy de acuerdo contigo
alberto aunque ya sabes que mi candidato
favorito era jean philippe lo que pasa
es que no parece que vaya a tener muchas
probabilidades de obtener finalmente la
nominación
en cualquier caso hillary si introduce
en su programa elementos muy positivos
alguno de los cuales lo cierto es que
podríamos tomar nota en españa por
ejemplo ella habla de darle facilidades
fiscales a las empresas que dicen
repartir una parte de sus beneficios con
los trabajadores y qué significa esto
dicho de otro modo bueno pues lo que
quiere es favorecer que el salario de
los trabajadores acabe finalmente
vinculado a la productividad al
rendimiento de la empresa algo que me
parece muy bueno para la flexibilidad y
la competitividad del tejido productivo
y además hillary también tiene
preocupaciones en elementos que son
claros aunque no estén en los
principales titulares por ejemplo
hillary contempla un plan de 5 mil
millones para favorecer la reinserción
de la por ejemplo intentar ya y en eeuu
es una de las paradas del mundo donde
realmente tienen un auténtico problema
por todo ello alberto salvo que john
cage sigue de la sorpresa yo también voy
con hillary y como milagrosamente
enrique yo coincidimos en algo pues no
voy a manejar la ecuación escapar y ha
sobrado una sorpresa para hillary
clinton hemos hablado a nuestros vídeos
post
la vida es como un surtido de galletas
y todos empezamos comiendo nos las de
chocolate después pasamos a las que
están rellenas de crema y finalmente
siempre queda esa galleta que no sabe a
nada
es cierto nadie quiere comérsela pero
alguien debe hacerlo para acabar con el
surtido es un deber moral tirar la caja
a la basura sin habérsele ha terminado
no es propio de américa hillary es esa
galleta si nadie sabe a ciencia cierta
lo que defiende probablemente no será la
mejor presidenta de los eeuu
pero está en política desde antes de que
jordi hurtado de salir en televisión y
al igual que el presentador de saber y
ganar ella tampoco ha envejecido
con amigos americanos tenéis que votar a
hillary clinton porque qué narices
porque es hillary clinton porque vas a
terminar votando la y lo sabes
hillary for america comete la galleta o
será el monstruo de las galletas quien
nos comerá todos